que le président de la république fixe
un cap c'est bien normal c'est ce que
l'on attend du leem ce que les habitants
des quartiers attendent c'est du concret
du concret du concret du concret sont
pas des mots la philosophique et choisi
les mots choisis parce que les mon
compte en politique
l'émancipation la dignité ça me va
plutôt bien parce que j'ai toujours
pensé qu'il fallait sortir de cette
espèce de paternalisme à l'ancienne de
cocooning des quartiers populaires mais
en termes concrets en termes d'ambitions
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui lie à l'arrêt
annonces de mesures déjà annoncées
certaines très positif dédoublement des
classes en zep en cp c'est une belle
mesure
c'est une mesure audacieuse moi dans ma
ville je l' ai mis en place et je peux
vous dire avec enthousiasme mais au-delà
de ça des enfants de mesures concrètes
annoncées aujourd'hui c'est cette
question du guichet unique des stages de
troisième
j'y suis favorable c'était un de mes
engagements à nantes en 2014 et c'est
léger quand sur un point précis la
consule la possibilité pour les mères
d'avoir accès au fichier des personnes
signalées pour possible radicalisation
le gouvernement a dit pourquoi pas mais
très encadrée est ce que vous êtes
favorable à avoir accès à ces fichiers
oui je crois que c'est nécessaire qu'il
y ait cette information mais
effectivement que les choses soient bien
régulé bien précisé me paraît aussi
utile mais juste un mot là-dessus parce
que ça me paraît tout à fait normal que
quand on parle des quartiers on parle de
ses sujets qu'on parle de la sécurité
qu'on parle de cette question des
fichiers s mais nos quartiers ce n'est
pas que ça nos quartiers c'est toute une
partie de la jeunesse française qui a
envie d'entreprendre
qu'est ce qu'on dit à cette jeunesse nos
quartiers c'est aussi des jeunes
diplômés on oublie trop souvent de le
dire des bac + 4 des bac + 5 qui ensuite
ne trouvent pas d'emploi sur mars ils
travaillent et là en terme d' annonce à
ce stade il n'y a rien geanah autant
dire que la pression pour le mois de
juillet est quand même très forte sur ce
sujet